[Music]
hello there so the new imposter mode hit
fortnite and squatting dog the guy with
a locker bundle in fortnite set up a
community game with a bunch of content
creators ranging from the millionaires
from top 5 gaming to other creators that
are just starting their youtube and
twitch journeys i'll link them all in
the description below if you want to go
show them some love this is my first
ever time being the imposter and i've
got to admit it went quite well so sit
your butt down for 10 minutes slap code
adamaru in the store and let's be the
imposter among them
yeah last at last
what's a good strat i'm completely
clueless
but i would like to be the first person
to win this game mode as an imposter
so we have 20 seconds on our cooldown
we can sabotage in about 11 seconds
they've already done three percent
okay
so basically i can't do anything for the
first 10 seconds i really should be
looking like i'm doing something look at
me i'm so doing something right now
right we can have a peely party
are you all on your own go dad thank you
very much for playing see you next time
and now i should be able to get away i
need a couple more doors
and then i should look fine
okay i think i'm clear from this let's
hope that pat's got one too
i look like i want friends
hey i need friends i'm scared of you too
i'm so scared
look how scared i am
okay okay lucas squatting dog and big j
can all vouch for me this is good
does it look like i'm using this
we can sabotage again now
we can disable assignments we can
teleport players we can't use appeali
for another 20 seconds that's
interesting
i need to look like i need a friend
do you trust me
bendy trust me ben he's not bothered at
all
okay so let's look like
load screen remember these on dvd
players where we try to get them in the
corner
so we got
if i've got one a pat's got one with two
down already
should we try and take another one
okay maybe not
all right i need to act dumb act dumb
act dumb i'm good at that bond all right
have you just seen that ben
why don't don't you dare right hoost box
and uh i think it's
lucas i've literally been standing next
to a dead body for probably 10-15
seconds so either they're blind and
haven't noticed it always vote for them
where was the bat
um i think it was where that was
the storm screens
i was doing store monitoring
next to lucas i turned around and the
body was right there i don't know
it's lucas and postbox i'm telling you
well i i've been with post box a lot of
this and even during the peely party and
me post box and iata been chill so i
don't know it's either both of them or
it's one of them
but they're both right next to a body i
had tunnel vision and i was very
interested in what the storm sing would
do it was underwhelming i can confirm
ben's uh story that we were hugging it
out during the peeley thing no i was
with ato and ben as well
i saw the thing as yeah big jones i
turned around the body was right there i
was like what the i didn't even expect
it to be there and lucas was next to me
as well lucas wasn't even there lucas
was looking at
storm monitoring
or it's one of them or both of them but
they were literally in a room it was
outside of the room literally in the
doorway to the point you couldn't get
out of the room
i saw it i turned i was like
getting a free ride which one who was it
was two people been eliminated tommy and
reddish didn't even see who it was yeah
i've not seen redditch at all
hey don't bring the attention which body
was it was it was it i mean it's totally
right i learned about youtube that's all
i'm going to say where was the body
again the one that you found um next to
those i don't know what it's called but
this
bit of the storm screens and when i say
it was in the room it was like blocking
the doorway so if it either happened
whilst they were in there or if they'd
gone in there before it's happened then
it was one of them because you can't get
past it without seeing it wait i got a
question
uh who eliminated tommy
please someone hold up
please
all right we're through this no one's
getting voted out here
[Music]
yoshi you gotta vote there brad how do
you feel about that
wait where is that problem i'm telling
you i'm sick of my conviction just
wondering right so he thinks it's lucas
so we can probably push him onto that
one later on
30 seconds to eliminate 20 seconds to
sabotage they're halfway through their
tasks
let's go and uh
hmm
no
let's leave you mr shotgun look like i'm
a friend look like i'm watching you do a
task
i trust you look now you trust me
because i trust you that's how it works
human behavior
right we have a sabotage ready
we have two people in there i think it's
time for another peely party
oh you've left him in there you left him
on his own you left him on his own
have you left your bodies up no he's not
in there oh you'll do
good night
and now we run away
i'm totally doing this task totally
doing this task
we definitely need to get a move on
oh maybe not
icebox no i know nothing all right
listen listen
what's up
i found it in the office and i saw no
one for like a solid 30 seconds prior
so if anyone saw anyone by the office or
going out of the office that wasn't
coming from the security like near
supply drop factory
let's speak up
lucas are you a professional at finding
corpses
i've only found one this is the first
time
so the answer is no
no no i'm not yep
a brief uh shall we say friendly hug in
the basement we're squatting dog and as
we're coming out of there that's great
by the
until until he sees us two together and
then he turns in the other direction and
as i was already on his case last time
even more suspicious than it was before
i'm thinking when i see them i'm
thinking maybe it's
could be both could not be so i stay
with them for a bit we're in weapons
that we walked up to weapons love
come on can't blame someone to be honest
i think it's for me to say something i
guess
big deer last time who did you think it
was
uh either lucas or postbox or both
do you stand by that now
um less suspicious of lucas it only in
the fact that dammit i saw him doing
something
they're gonna vote
he found it in the office right
that's my office
and the only two other people that i saw
there were squatting dog and big john so
and you put the blame on lucas before
which i put the blame i put the baby on
both of them and i still stand by post
box but i'm not so sure about lucas now
would an imposter report someone with
absolutely no one to throw the blame to
we might have to throw pat under the bus
here my prediction is just that big
jones and squatty dog are working
together here and we still need two in a
good job
i wish that was the case but yeah i i
mean i did give him a hug but um he's
legit now he's legit yeah you could have
killed me and i could have killed you in
that situation
post was awkwardly watching
yeah
he came straight towards me and then
when he saw scott coming out of the room
afterwards he turned and run off i'm
voting post
damn it
they're gonna follow him they're gonna
follow him
i'll skip i'd better not like if i look
like a i'm gonna look like i'm
supporting him if it's just two votes in
the middle oh crap please don't notice
the two boats in the middle everyone
it's obvious who i am
see pat
surprise
let's go good call out
ggs
okay we gotta you gotta win this for pat
come on patrick patricia i have no idea
what kind of pat you called
we're going to do this for pat
hmm so we have to kill two people or we
have to kill one person and firmly set
the blame
at one of the others right squatting
doesn't trust
ear
um john doesn't trust squatting
so i need to blame one of those too
peely
party oh crap crap crap crap crap crap
oh no i've been caught oh no i've been
caught please be someone dumb enough to
run this way please please please but
thank you so much thank you so much
thank you so much
what should i do what should i do if
we've got to get someone blamed we have
to get someone blamed so let's go stand
by it
please be still there please be still
there someone
but yes come over
come on come on come on please press it
before it's over please press it before
it's over
yes i should have waited for the banana
in in retrospect right act cool act cool
okay i was in a tricky situation here
um
in retrospect i should have
i definitely should have uh waited for
the banana thing to end there was
somebody on the corpse
of the
the that was my glowy thing i was
waiting for it to be over to see your
name then report you but you reported
quicker than i could i didn't see any
murder anything just you were closest
and i was waiting for the timer to tick
down to report it you were next to it
for a while there was there's a timer
there's a timer i was waiting for it to
completely finish so i could see your
face because i don't know who you are
when you're yeah exactly but i i don't
think there's a timer to report
unless you're a killer
there's no there's no time at all is
that
then why didn't you a timer for what oh
you were waiting for the bananas to end
to see yeah i was waiting for my face to
end so i could report and say you were
there but okay we've just done it
honestly instead but right right yeah i
also just
impulsively did it because i thought you
were going to kill me
but you ran towards me you would have
run away from me if you thought well i
had to i had to like report it right so
you were jumping around it and i snuck
in and grabbed it
okay
but
uh
what's hard about this is we could both
be innocent or
like i'm i know i'm innocent and i don't
know if you know you're in a center i'm
not pretty sure i am okay then it could
50 50 and get rid of one of us and then
vote the other one or would that mean no
it wouldn't work but also like didn't
didn't your i'm and i'm not trying to
pass the blame we only have 40 seconds
didn't irtel
uh vouch for
our imposter our last imposter
no i can't remember but you must be able
to tell me because i've literally thrown
him under the bus straight away like i
i knew it was him from the first round
so
unless i've jumped on my teammate
straight away as an imposter it makes no
sense for me to be the imposter all i
said was that i started to trust lucas
and now he is dead oh that's right that
i saw in the office was you squatting
dog next to big john and big john
got postpartum as the imposter so i
think it's you
okay you can think it's me it's not i'm
voting adam though because we were both
at the scene and i'm innocent
[Music]
no
it worked
i can't believe that worked
i have a family
i'm gonna go out dancing
what played we got this
have we won
oh my god
what what
um
we have to kill one and we haven't we've
got 30 seconds when does they can just
re they can just bolt me out straight
away i don't have a chance here
i can't sabotage for 12 seconds
um
make it look like i'm doing a task
come on follow me follow me follow me
they're gonna i've got it i've got to
take out here i've got to take out here
chase them a bit sabotage so when come
on sabotage dammit
thank you
please don't work please don't work it
doesn't work right it's all on this if
they get back to the middle i'm done i
have to kill one of them now or it's
over stay there stay there big job
good job adam
where you were like 10 meters behind me
what did you just launch at me
i have no idea i got you i thought it
was too far away too
i can hear someone but he sounds like
he's about a good 10 20 meters behind me
[Music]